hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
mind-blowing science fiction series from
black mirror season four called black
museum
in the middle of nowhere while waiting
for her car to be charged niche comes
across a building named black museum
which keeps all authentic criminological
artifacts it's supposed to open at 11 am
but then she is approached by the museum
owner rollo haynes who explains that the
place is not for the faint-hearted and
offers to give her a tour as she is the
first visitor today
after doing some inspection through her
stuff they proceed to the main room of
the museum
as they walk niche explains that she is
out this way to visit her father and
celebrate his birthday as he lives
nearby the first step they come across
is a device that looks like an
electronic hair net hane starts to tell
the story about the stuff and a little
bit about his background
he was a neuroscientist for st juniper a
university hospital in new york which
offers free health care for people in
exchange for being allowed to be a test
subject to their experimental treatment
haynes approaches dr peter dawson who
just failed his surgery in regards to
testing an experimental neurological
implant he then explains that his team
has just discovered a device which
allows information to transfer from one
brain to another the experiment failed
but they found an interesting discovery
when one of his employees spilled hot
coffee all over the first mouse kenny
the device enables the second mouse
hector to feel the same physical
sensation as kenny hector will feel the
same burn sensation as kenny but it will
take no damage at all
because of that they manage to create a
receiver that can be implemented to the
human's body
its purpose is to enable all the doctors
to feel their patients pain without
having to experience the physical damage
so that they would be able to cure the
patients in the right way
interested with the offer the device
then is applied to the doctor's neck
thanks to that dawson becomes an expert
at diagnosing and treating his patients
he also manages to save a lot of lives
it turns out that the implant also
enables him to receive pleasurable
sensations
dawson also uses the device to enhance
sex with her girlfriend by feeling her
sensation causing him to experience male
and female orgasm at the same time
everything is going well for the doctor
until one night where a poisoned senator
is brought into the hospital dawson is
connected when the senator suddenly dies
it is the first time he experiences
death
dawson blacks out for a few minutes but
when he awakes they discover that
nothing is wrong with his body
however he soon finds that the side
effect is that he now experiences pain
as pleasure the more pain he feels the
more pleasure he gets or people called
it masochist he starts demanding for
rough sex but when his girlfriend gets
tired at it he then begins hanging
around at the hospital waiting for
patience and craving for pain
at one night when an old lady who
suffered a heart attack is brought to
the emergency room dawson starts to
connect himself to her and uses her
suffering for personal pleasure he
intends to buy some time so that the
other doctor won't do the treatment but
eventually the security guards have to
pull dawson away from her the next day
he visits haynes but he explains that he
is not able to reverse the procedure so
the doctor has to be removed from the
hospital
one night dawson finds that hurting
himself will also bring the pleasurable
sensation
addicted to that he begins mutilating
himself
not enough with that he also tortures
and kills a homeless man with a drill
by the time police find him the extreme
sensations of pleasure has caused him to
fall into a coma and is put in the
hospital until now
back to the present haynes is covered by
sweat and niche offers him a bottle of
water since the museum ac is broken
after that they move to the one of the
saddest objects in the place which is a
monkey doll and he starts to tell the
story behind it
jack and carrie are a happy couple with
their new baby when carrie wants to take
a photo of her husband and son she
suddenly gets hit by a truck and falls
into a coma
jack visits his wife regularly but she
never awakes
they communicate using a neuro
technology which allows carrie to give
yes or no responses
one day haynes approaches the husband
and offers a procedure for her wife
which transfers carrie's consciousness
into his brain and allows her to see and
hear everything he does
it also enables jack to talk to her
again
at first he is uncertain when told that
they need to kill carrie first but kerry
agrees by responding from the device
they begin the operation and is
successful
kerry is now able to feel the hug from
their grown son parker
however the shared consciousness begins
to take a toll on the couple as jack
feels a lack of privacy and carrie keeps
complaining about whatever he does
the couple then meets hanes who offers
jack more privilege by allowing him to
put carrie on pause
tired of being watched jack decides to
put his wife on a pause for weeks but
this action just infuriates her whenever
he allows her consciousness again making
the relationship worse
then jack meets emily and the two begin
dating not happy with carrie disturbing
their relationship they meet haynes and
emily forces him to transfer carries
consciousness out of him completely
deleting the consciousness means death
for carrie sohain suggests transferring
her into a monkey doll with a camera
which is then given to their son parker
unfortunately the doll can only speak
two phrases monkey loves you and monkey
needs a hug
carrie is furious and keeps spamming the
button but emily threatens to delete her
completely if she does not behave
as parker grows up he eventually gets
bored with the doll and abandons it with
carrie trapped inside it in the present
haynes claims that he was fired because
of that invention as it is perceived
inhuman and illegal
he also reveals that carrie is still
inside the monkey doll since it is
illegal to delete her they then move to
the prime exhibit of the museum which is
a dismal hologram projection of clayton
lee killer of a lady named denise
stockley
the idea behind this is to transfer the
consciousness of people on the death row
so haines approaches clayton and
persuades him to sign over the rights
which allows him to use his post-death
consciousness in exchange for money to
support the killer's family clayton's
wife is worried at first but he assures
that the amount of money she will
receive will be enough to fund their
kids
after his execution haynes manages to
resurrect clayton but as a hologram
inside the museum
he sets clayton up in an execution
display in which the visitors could pull
a lever to make clayton scream as he
feels the agony of being electrocuted
without killing him the visitors will
also be rewarded a keychain souvenir
displaying a copy of clayton screaming
in agony this torture machine has turned
the museum into big success as it is
usually fill with visitors who are happy
to see the killer gets tortured over and
over again
haynes explains that each electrocution
is set to last 10 seconds if it reaches
more than 15 seconds it would break the
hologram and could erase it while
explaining haynes suddenly starts
choking and discovers that he has been
poisoned by niche
she also has sabotaged the museum air
conditioner so that haynes would become
thirsty and accept the water offer
surprisingly niche reveals herself to be
clayton's daughter she then claims that
his father is actually innocent and
there have been several actions done to
support his father but it never works as
the state never cares
the least thing the protesters could do
is to post a threat on social media
which ended up hurting the museum's
popularity and decreasing the visitors
significantly because of that the museum
now attracts wealthy sadists who would
pay more to torture clayton exceeding
its limit turning him into empty shell
not dead but hardly alive until one day
nisha's mom comes to see what has
happened to her husband depressed she
takes a bottle of pills and vodka
causing her death by overdose
haines then dies and niche transfers his
consciousness into clayton's hologram
she pulls the lever to the maximum
causing haines to experience the full
force of being electrocuted while also
finally putting clayton's consciousness
into rest
after that along with her monkey doll
and the souvenir containing haines
screaming in agony niche walks out from
the museum before returning to the car
she removes an electronic device from
the ac compressor which causes it
couldn't work and sets it on fire
at the end of the film niche is caught
having a conversation with her mom
revealing that they have been sharing
consciousness
niche drives away with her mother
shedding joyful tears as the museum is
engulfed in flames
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching